So life appeared on planet earth about 3.6
billion years ago. But for the bulk of that
time, organisms, life on the planet, was not
able to see. Around 500 million years ago
there was a revolution in the technology of
life and the sense of vision appeared, and
it appeared very quickly across a number of
species and it led to a great diversity in
the forms of life. So at this point 500 million
years ago called the Cambrian explosion when
suddenly all these vision-enabled life forms
started to roam the planet.
One of the earliest and perhaps most successful
of those life forms is the trilobite, and
here I have a fossilised trilobite. They appeared
500 something million years ago and they lived
on the planet for something like 270 million
years. So they are an animal with a segmented
body and they had two fairly primitive, by
modern standards, compound eyes. And the sense
of vision gave animals a competitive advantage.
If an animal could see another animal, perhaps
it was a hunting animal and it wanted to prey
on that other animal, if it had a sense of
vision it had a real advantage, it didn’t
just have to blindly bump into it. He can
actually see where that animal is and go after
it and consume it. And similarly if you were
a prey animal, the sort of animal that someone
might want to eat, then if you had a sense
of vision and you had eyes then you could
sense a predator coming and you could take
some evasive action. So vision led to this…
almost an arms race on planet earth as predators
and prey animals gain the sense of vision
and they improved the sense of vision until
we have the sort of very sophisticated vision
in very, very many animals today.
So the sense of vision appeared on planet
earth about 540 million years ago. And when
it appeared it was a game changer. In fact,
the sense of vision was so effective that,
over time, ten different sorts of eye designs
have evolved. For instance, the lensed eye
that we have, the compound eye that a insect
has, the strange reflector based eyes that
scallops have and so on. So there are ten
different designs of eyes on the planet. And
the lensed eye, like the one we have, has,
in fact, been invented seven times across
different animal species and across time.
So to me these facts argue that vision is
a really important and really effective way
of sensing what is going on in the world around
you.
Now of course vision needs light in order
to operate, we need the scene to be illuminated
with ambient light. Photons reflected from
the scene into our eyes, they fall on the
retina and create some neural stimulus. Absolutely
has to have a source of light, but of course
we have evolved on a planet next to a really
bright star. So light is in abundance. It
is a very logical solution to the problem.
We have an abundant source of light and we
have evolved the sensor which has got many
advantages, but primarily the ability to sense
what is going on at a distance beyond our
fingertips.
So how did the sense of vision evolve? There
is a lot of speculation about this, but generally
it is accepted that light sensitive cells
appeared on the bodies of very primitive life
forms a long time ago, more than 500 million
years ago, and they have the ability to sense
brightness or light. And perhaps this was
useful to work out which way was up and which
way was down and maybe you could see the shadow
of something going across and that was a useful
thing to have. So these photoreceptors could
sense light and they were connected by some
sort of primitive nerve fibres to some sort
of primitive brain.
This was clearly a useful idea because over
time the photoreceptors were arranged into
a curve, or in three dimensions, into a cup.
And this allowed the photoreceptors to respond
to rays that came from a particular direction
in space. And this was more useful than just
knowing that there was something bright out
there, now we knew the direction of the bright
thing and this conferred some advantage. This
design was refined over time, the chamber
became filled with water, perhaps they had
better optical properties, and then there
was sort of coverings evolved. And then lenses
evolved. Until we get to something like the
human eye today were we have, you know, protective
layers, and we have lenses. We have an iris,
which regulates the amount of light which
falls onto the retinas. So we can operate
quite well in low light and bright light conditions.
The photoreceptors, which are this yellow
layer shown here, are connected by a bunch
of nerve fibres, the optic nerve, which carry
those stimuli to the optical or visual parts
of the brain. And that is actually the part
of the brain located at the back of our head.